the conservative MP Steve Baker is an
archbrexic tier and was one of the
leaders of the back bench pressure group
known as the European research group ERG
he's now in government tears in Northern
Ireland Minister and has been giving his
reaction to the deal
and there you are joining us live Mr
Baker very good to talk to you um well
does this framework wins a framework as
it's now being called does it in your
view meet the seven tests of the
democratic unionist party and the
goodest knows how many tests of the ERG
yes it does in my view this restores
Northern Ireland's place in the Union
what it does is it makes sure that
Northern Ireland is in the UK's internal
market for goods in both directions
without burdensome process so just as it
should be it restores Northern Ireland's
place in the union with things like
medicines traveling with pets you know
this is a taxation absolutely crucial
point and a major win and finally there
is dealing with the Democratic deficit
by the petition of concern mechanism the
assembly in Northern Ireland will be
able to say no to new EU law that's a
terrific breakthrough it shows great
statesmanship for one of a better word
for it from Ursula vandelayan I I'm just
terrifically pleased that I can
earnestly say that this is a moment when
at last one chapter of our national
story May close and a new one may begin
in a new spirit of partnership and
friendship with Ireland and with the EU
okay and what about the ERG you
mentioned the dup7 test okay we've been
through that and presumably they're
going through it line by line right
right now to uh bring us their opinion
on it what about the ERG though because
you and I talked for what for the last
four or five years particularly during
those Theresa May years and and the
tortuous negotiations around brexit and
particularly Northern Ireland and uh you
were four square against the checkers
deal that Theresa May brought forward
this one works for you does it work for
the other members of the ERG
well I very much hope so but if I may
say so John if I recall correctly I
launched conservatives for Britain on
your program on my birthday on the 6th
of June 2015 so it's been a long journey
together but what I remember is that the
it yeah yeah yes it's a particularly
moving moment to book ends this journey
with you but the the ERG will like the
dup read every word every detail of 119
pages of legal text plus uh the command
paper and everything else that's
provided they will scrutinize it all in
detail this is existential for
eurosceptics as it is for the dup but I
I'm very confident I met them earlier
and I explained to them why having read
the text I'm backing this deal and
earnestly and enthusiastically I'm I've
said to them I very much hope that when
they've read the text themselves that
they will also feel able in good faith
to back this deal and move on and I do
think it's the right thing to do I think
this is a win and I think it's very
important in politics to know when
you've had a win-win solution for all
sides Bank it and move forward words and
this is a time to bank what is a radical
Improvement for the people of Northern
Ireland and we should we should Bank it
and move on there's always going to be
something that some ideologue would
condemn and some unionists are so hard
line I think they put a they put a moat
between the North and the South but
those those ladies and gentlemen are
never going to be satisfied by anything
I think that for pragmatic unionists
looking at the full spectrum of this
deal in the detail I I think we'll find
that they're able to back this as I have
in good faith with a whole heart and
move our country forward
and Mr Baker do you think there are any
ideologues as you put it left in the ERG
who are going to say well okay we used
to respect Steve Baker but he's taken
the Shilling he's got a ministerial job
he would be saying this wouldn't he
well I think that they know that as late
as the last week and indeed as late as
yesterday I was going into number 10
thinking I might have to resign over
this deal but really The Clincher for me
has been the Democratic deficit point
it's an extraordinary achievement to
have this storm won't break I've read
the legal text it's a real thing it's an
incredible achievement by Richie sanak
to have got it and I think it shows a
great foresight equal actually to the
Belfast Good Friday agreement that the
EU has delivered it and I think as we
approach the anniversary all of us need
to move Beyond you know whatever and you
know animosities I think I've been
through personally enough that people
will take for granted that I would
resign if I felt I couldn't support the
deal so you know I'm backing this with a
good heart other people will read the
text if they conclude they can't well
I'll take the hits but I think actually
the vast majority of sensible pragmatic
colleagues which I'm sure is all of my
colleagues in Parliament they'll read
the text they'll decide this is a good
moment to bank the success and move on
great talking to Mr Baker and thank you
so much for being so Frank